Le gouvernement fédéral
imposera la vaccination
contre la COVID-19
à tous ses fonctionnaires
et employés des sociétés d'État.
On fait le point
avec Me Julius Grey,
avocat en droits de la personne.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Est-ce que vous attendez à ce
que ce soit contesté?
- Je pense que ça peut être
contesté et il est évident qu'il
y a une violation des droits et
libertés mais ça ne met pas fin
au départ, parce que les
violations peuvent être
justifiées. La charte n'est pas
un carcan et une camisole de
force et il y a beaucoup de cas
où les tribunaux décident que
malgré la violation technique ou
autre de la charte se justifie.
- Quelles sont les conditions
pour qu'un juge dise que ça
viole la charte, mais on va
quand même le permettre,
autoriser cette vaccination
obligatoire?
- Il y a trois tests principaux.
Le premier c'est ce que le
gouvernement...
ça n'a pas de doute ici, c'est
pour mater la pandémie. Est-ce
qu'il y a un lien entre la
vaccination et l'atteinte du
but? Oui, tous les médecins sont
d'accord que la vaccination
diminue la propagation. Là où il
peut y avoir un débat, c'est sur
le troisième test : est-ce que
c'est n'est pas excessif, est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose de moins
intrusif qui pourrait être fait
pour atteindre le but? Dans
certains cas, je pense que ça
peut être oui, quelqu'un qui ne
peut pas se faire vacciner pour
des raisons de santé, des choses
de cette nature, à ce moment on
pourrait faire des dépistages
fréquents, le port du masque et
peut-être le télétravail. Mais
pour la majorité des gens, c'est
soutenable, mais si je devais
parier, je dirais que le
gouvernement va gagner. Il y a
plusieurs raisons. Dans le cas
des crises, et on est en crise,
par exemple les lois de mesures
de guerre et tout cela,
généralement les cours sont
réticentes à casser.
Deuxièmement, le cours
fonctionne dans la société. Et
non elles ne sont pas
extérieures et il est évident
que cette mesure est populaire.
Un gouvernement ne les
imposerait pas la veille d'une
élection si ce n'était pas
populaire. Donc le juge qui vit
dans la société sont sujets à la
même vision du monde que les
autres citoyens.
- On a un contexte de pandémie,
de quatrième vague, et on ne
veut pas revivre de délestage
dans les hôpitaux. Vous dîtes
sur le troisième point que vous
avez invoqué, est-ce qu'il y a
de moins en moins contraignant,
on comprend que le gouvernement
aurait peut-être des exceptions
pour les gens qui ont des
conditions de santé concernent
ne pas être vaccinés. Mais il y
a des gens qui refusent d'être
vaccinés pour des raisons
idéologiques et d'autres raisons
que d'autres raisons de santé,
est-ce que ces gens pourraient
dire on va rester avec du
télétravail. Ça nous évite de
nous faire vacciner, mais on
reste un employé de l'État.
- C'est un argument soutenable
et ce dans notre travail peut
être fait par télétravail, qui
n'ont pas de contact avec le
public, ce serait un argument
soutenable.
Aussi, sur le plan religieux ou
autre, les gens pourraient dire
la conscience et cela est
soutenable. Je ne me jurais pas
si je devais présenter cet
argument devant la cour, mais je
pense que ça réussirait pas et
je rappellerai assez Jean la
Cour suprême a ordonné à une
musulmane d'avoir sa photo sur
son permis, sinon elle pouvait
s'abstenir de conduire mais elle
ne peut pas avoir d'exception.
Je pense que la religion, oui
dans certains cas ça peut mener
à un accommodement, mais ce
n'est pas un accommodement
automatique.
La conclusion à laquelle je
viens, ce que le gouvernement a
fait une chose qui est très
défendable. Il se peut qu'il va
y avoir un argument, certains
individus pourront présenter des
arguments intéressants, mais
somme toute, je pense que le
gouvernement va en sortir
vainqueur.
- Merci pour votre regard, M.
Grey.
Un autre regard, sur lui du
monde de la santé avec le
Docteur Patrick Bellemare.
Il est intensiviste.
Bonsoir.
Vous en pensez quoi de cette
idée de vaccination obligatoire
pour les fonctionnaires
fédéraux? Êtes-vous d'accord?
- C'est difficile d'être en
désaccord avec une mesure qui
nous permet de cesser de vivre
l'isolement qu'on a vécu comme
société au cours de dernières
années. La seule façon
alternative d'endiguer une
pandémie comme celle qu'on a
vécue à la vaccination de masse,
se soit infecté tout le monde,
soit imposé une quarantaine
permanente.
On aura compris au cours de la
dernière année que l'isolement
imposé avec la fermeture
artificielle de la société a
permis de contrôler la vitesse
de distribution de virus dans la
population, mais très clairement
à plusieurs reprises, on a dû
réfléchir activement à des
scénarios qui nous faisaient
déborder des ressources du
système de santé. Quand on
arrive là, je pense que dans une
logique de mesures de guerre,
cette métaphore a été utilisée à
répétition et pour le cas de la
pandémie, si on n'avait pas
utilisé les mesures qui ont été
utilisées en début de pandémie,
on aurait été débordé.
Clairement.
- Vous recevez des patients qui
sont atteints de la COVID et qui
ont des complications aux soins
intensifs et ce que vous
constatez, parce qu'il y a des
gens de plus en plus vaccinés,
qui recevez-vous aux soins
intensifs? Est-ce qu'il y a des
gens vaccinés ou des noms
vaccinés?
- Ce sont très
exceptionnellement des gens
vaccinés. Dans la grande
majorité des cas, ce ne sont des
gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
ou pas vaccinés complètement.
Légende pas vaccinée
complètement, j'en ai pas vu
dans ma pratique. Je peux vous
dire qu'il existe deux de gens
vaccinés complètement et immuno
supprimer qui ont présenté une
COVID sévère. J'ai un exemple
récent d'une toute jeune
transplantée qui est décédée
après avoir reçu toutes ses de
vaccination.
- On voit que les gouvernements
provinciaux et fédéraux
utilisent tous les outils qui
sont accessibles pour pousser
les gens vers la vaccination. On
dit que la quatrième vague ce
sera la vague des non vaccinés.
Est-ce que ça pourrait avoir un
impact sur les hôpitaux et un
impact sur le délestage?
- Regardez les courbes,
on voit où on est rendu et on
est clairement pas au sommet et
au moment où on se parle dans
l'environnement auquel moi je
suis habitué, il y a autour de
15 % de la clientèle
hospitalisée au soin intensif
qui est porteuse de la COVID
sévère. C'est très facile
d'imaginer que ce pourcentage
pourrait augmenter, peut-être
pas pour occuper l'entièreté de
la ressource de soins intensifs,
mais certainement à un point
suffisant pour compromettre
l'accès à d'autres services.
C'est un bout de film qu'on ne
peut pas revoir se dérouler
devant nous.
- Une dernière question.
Monsieur Dubé demande au fédéral
de resserrer le retour aux
frontières, il dit que ça n'a
pas de bon sens qu'on n'est pas
de mesures obligatoires. Est-ce
que c'est un problème?
- Il faudrait que je sois posté
à la douane voulais dire avec
certitude.
On voit souvent des gens qui
sont pas complètement vaccinés
ou non vaccinés et ce n'est pas
un problème de voyage à
l'étranger. On a quelques
voyageurs sont revenus et qui
avait été peu immunisé avant
leur voyage et à chaque fois, il
s'agissait d'un